wie frei können wir entscheiden das ist
hier die frage
lassen wir alles mit uns geschehen im
labor des lebens wie stark scheuern
unbekannte kommandos unser verhalten
ohne dass wir es ahnen
ein experiment mit diesem und veränderte
1905 die welt sein herrchen der
mediziner iwan petrowitsch pawlow gaben
zu fressen und läutete gleichzeitig ein
glöckchen nachdem pavlov dies mehrere
male wiederholt hatte läutete er nur
noch das glöckchen ohne fressen und
trotzdem begann dar und speichel zu
bilden
der paarlauf schill reflex lauf hatte
das prinzip der konditionierung entdeckt
er beweist das verhalten zu großen
teilen auf reaktionen basiert denn
bestimmte signale lösen ganz bestimmte
reflexe aus das kläppchen von damals tat
sich für uns heutzutage in vielerlei
gestalt werden löst reflexe aus wir
kaufen kaufen und kaufen
und wer weiß schon auf welche signale
wie reagieren der paarlauf reflex hat
längst auch die politik gut sagte eine
jahr sagt die anleger sicher reflexartig
nein
die reflexzonen des alltags werden immer
größer belohnt wird wer viel leistet und
viel leistet wer sich pushen lässt im
zeitalter der selbstoptimierung wie viel
an unbewusster dressur lassen mehr zu an
fremdsteuerung durch reize durch signale
von aus oder sind er längst schon zu
pawlowschen runden montiert die zu allem
nur eins sagen ja ja ja und ja